prima che voi di chat e che cosa cazzo
ce ne frega a noi di questo titolo che
hai messo la risposta è mamme meno male
il fatto è che ad alcune persone frega e
questa roba mi fa girare cazzo dal
titolo non potrebbe sembrare però questo
è partito come video incazzatura sono
ormai mesi se non anni
la gente mi caga le palle per un
determinato argomento affari ma perché
non riuscì con chi stai perché tv la tua
vita privata privata perché secondo te
si chiama vita privata io non racconto i
cazzi miei alla gente però sono
costretto a questo punto a farlo un po
per il click day the un po perché mi
hanno cacciato un cazzo siccome tutti
quanti mi chiedono di continuo affari ma
non c'è la ragazza o meglio affari c'è
la ragazza però non lo dici oppure
affari non hai la ragazza perché ciò che
i videogiochi quindi chi gioca
videogiochi non ha la ragazza si questo
succedeva nel 2000 adesso non è così
adesso pensate vi è chi giochi video
games è considerato un figo quelli che
indossano i capelli del cazzo non ancora
però pian piano ci arriveremo allora
attualmente io non sono fidanzato punto
questo appunto ma anche poi
concretamente alcuni mi scrivono fa
rimasi finanziato concretamente perché
ho fatto un video concretamente dio
buono regala cosa cazzo vuol dire c'era
valore non può fare un video con
un'altra persona dell'altro sesso perché
devono stare insieme ma cristo santo e
che la gente scrive nei commenti a fa
visita con mia cugina quel cazzo l'hanno
lasciato cugina quindi faccio chiarezza
una volta per tutte se per caso io un
giorno dovessi fidanzarmi come solo sono
diversi altri youtuber che giocano ai
videogiochi non lo direi comunque perché
è la mia vita privata è privata
diversamente da quando avevo iniziato a
fare video perché quando ho iniziato io
a fare video ero fidanzato
che la ragazza che conoscono i miei fan
quelli che mi seguono da più tempo e
quindi al tempo era una cosa pubblica la
domanda che sorge spontanea mezzo mondo
perché si sente in dovere di chiederlo è
ma favi
ma dopo di lei si è stato mai con
un'altra ragazza va bene sputtaniamo
quindi la vita privata un'altra volta
la risposta è sì ok perché abdel sento
anch'io essere umano succede poi voi vi
chiederete come fa qualcuno a sceglierti
se indossi sti cappelli che fai
veramente ridere cazzo quello non lo so
manco io però
c'è anche da dire che quello che vedete
dentro la videocamera non è quello che
vedete magari fuori dalla videocamera
magari alcune persone non ci arrivano
però vabbè quindi adesso che ho aperto
il discorso e quindi facciamoci cazzi
miei fino alla fine vi racconterò un po
come è andata la mia situazione
sentimentale sta veramente facendo in
questo video
negli ultimi tempi allora la prima
ragazza la conoscete tutti quindi lei la
passiamo e le altre ragazze con le quali
sono stato per evitare di invadere la
loro privacy inventerò dei nomi fittizi
dopo diletta che è stata la mia prima
ragazza sono stato con una ragazza di
nome gertrude che abitava a milano io mi
ero trasferito a milano da poco perché
appunto un po per registrare il film un
po perché sono andato via di casa perché
volevo provare essere un po più
indipendente e niente per un paio di
mesi sono stato con questa ragazza che
era mia fan sì l'ho detto e che bello
però aveva 24 anni vengono pubblicherò
mai questo video io so già che sto
registrando le lo pubblicherò mai poi
sono partito per il marocco e stando
lontano da casa non ne sentivo tanto la
mancanza e questa cosa qua mi dava
abbastanza fastidio perché io quando sto
con una persona in genere spero che
quella persona di riesca a trasmettermi
qualcosa nel senso che quando non ci sei
insieme mi manca è una cosa che è molto
importante per me quindi se manca questo
fattore
secondo me è una relazione non può
funzionare dal mio punto di vista questa
è una mia caratteristica che ho sempre
parlato chiaramente con le persone
sempre e quindi glielo dissi glielo
dissi è però sempre meglio essere
sinceri che portare avanti una cosa nel
tempo e poi diventa tutta una merda
perché non sei stato in grado di avere
le palle di dirlo quindi mi lasciai al
tempo con gertrude quando tornai a
milano e lì il bel mandrillone che sono
inizia un'altra mia storia che questa è
bellissima come inizia perché sembra la
storia di un film perché questa ragazza
con la quale sono stato l'ho conosciuta
sul set del film che ho fatto e sembra
veramente un film 6 conoscersi sul set
sembra una storia invece no è vero è
successo 1 0 per le riprese di che in
terapia praticamente alcuni fan erano
venuti a trovarmi io sono uscito dal
tendone dove facciamole ripreso il fatto
le foto con tutti mentre scattavo queste
foto c'erano delle comparse che le
comparse sono quegli attori che non
hanno un ruolo nel in un film ma passano
sullo sfondo una di queste comparse è
stata appunto la mia ragazza successiva
perché ha visto che stavo facendo le
foto con i fan è andata a chiedere a
quei fan che io fossi i fan gli hanno
risposto a lui e fa vj è questa ragazza
che chiameremo castro giovanna sapeva
chi ero però non era mia fan ha visto
qualche video che voleva venire a
chiedermi una foto solo che lei come me
non ha le palle di favale lei è una
ragazza quindi se ci avesse le palle
sarebbe un problema e in quel caso ne
avrei sentitevi dolori siccome lei non
aveva il coraggio di di venirmi a
parlare ma io di andare a parlare lei ne
avrei avuto 100 volte meno era con una
sua amica che le ha dato una pedata nel
culo spingendola verso di me e io stavo
parlando con lorenzo e mi vedo sta
ragazza gli arrivi mi giro c'è la sua
ragazza di mi stava correndo in
contromano che mi stava correndo
incontro per abbracciarmi sufficiente
stava accadendo e me la ritrovo davanti
che sia stata la mia faccia
all'inizio è una è una e una femmina è
una che ha le tette come si cattura
dammi una poche boa ma tu sei fa vj si
sono famiglie ei ciao ci siamo fatti una
foto ce l'ha scattata lorenzo lorenzo
che questo ragazzo bello vicino lo
conoscesse siccome è un po un testa di
minchia però in quel caso è stato un
super utile quindi grazie fratello mio
se non ci fossi tu non avrei rimorchiato
un pene mentre faceva la foto si scatta
la foto diceva cose tipo ma come siete
carini manovra del genere io ero viola
in faccia ero di questo colore anzi è
rosso così dopo che lorenzo ha scattato
la foto la ragazza mi dice non ho dato
un esame universitario per guardare i
tuoi video cazzata mondiale nella vita
va bene a gastro giovanna che cazzo ti
sei inventato non ci ho creduto neanche
in quel momento e io le ho risposto a
mi dispiace è lorenzo che stava
ascoltando la conversazione ha detto beh
allora faville devi offrire
mi chiamo favi perché se mi chiamo
lorenzo anch'io non si capisce più un
cazzo lorenzo mi ha detto va favi allora
le devi offrire una cena per questo come
minimo è la tipa fa è come minimo sì e
io no
se la paga lei sono tirchi avevo
risposto va bene poi abbiamo iniziato a
sentirci mica che vi do beautiful sto
facendo
fatto sta che con questa storia è durata
praticamente quanto la mia prima un anno
e mezzo anche un po di più è durata fino
ad agosto di quest'anno e poi poi niente
semplicemente noi youtubers e parlo in
generale abbiamo una difficoltà nel fare
questo lavoro che trovare del tempo
libero sembra una stronzata veramente
sembra una stronzata dirlo ma è vero non
è tanto il video in sé che ti porta via
tempo ma più che altro devi organizzare
il video devi sapere che non puoi andare
da qualche parte perché se no non puoi
registrare il video per il giorno dopo
io faccio video anche la domenica quindi
io non ho giorni di pausa e quindi non
posso dedicarmi molto alla mia vita
privata
ciò significa che io e questa ragazza ci
vedevamo poor's pur essendo abbastanza
vicini ci vedevamo una volta a settimana
che non è
il massimo per una storia ok e quindi io
continuavo stare bene con lei però
continuavo a dirle guarda se ti pesa
questa cosa a me dispiace essere un peso
invece non lei continua a dire no va
bene no va bene va benissimo non ti
preoccupare perché lei ovviamente capiva
la mia situazione a lungo andare questa
è una cosa che va a deteriorare un po
quello che il rapporto perché hai poco
tempo io in questo periodo veramente
poco poco poco tempo ma ripeto non solo
perché devo stare a registrare il video
anche perché magari quando sono con lei
o dei pensieri del tipo e ma devo
registrare quello perché se faccio
quell'altro video poi non va bene cioè
fare lo youtube e stressante sotto certi
punti di vista e quindi tutto questo
casino è andato a deteriorare quello che
era il rapporto ea un certo punto
abbiamo deciso insieme di interrompere
il rapporto abbiamo deciso insieme una
cosa che capita raramente perché in
genere nelle relazioni c'è chi lascia
chi viene lasciato invece quella volta
lì abbiamo deciso proprio insieme di
fare questa cosa ed è giusto così
da un certo punto di vista è stato super
positivo perché è la mia prima storia
che finisco senza mandare tutto a
[ __ ]
lei è l'unica ragazza con la quale può
ancora la possibilità di sentirmi di
sapere come sta di dire di chiederle se
va tutto bene sono contentissimo di
sentirla quando mi capita ed è una cosa
molto rara è bella perché molto
probabilmente le mie altre ex vorrebbero
strangolarmi nelson basta c'è io non
sono anche perché ho fatto questo video
non sto con cugine di meschini di lo zio
peppo non le conosco venere privata una
cosa del genere è difficilissimo ragazzi
ve lo giuro bisogna stare attenti che
quando mi fanno le foto non le facciano
insieme bisogna stare attenti che su
instagram montague in una ragazza in
questione bisogna stare attenti che lei
non esca fuori nelle foto perché poi la
gente dice chi è quella madonna dio mio
bisogna tener conto del fatto che ci
sono dei fan che non sanno rispettare la
privacy e non ne faccio una colpa ai
ragazzini che si mettono in mezzo in
queste discussioni non gliene faccio una
colpa perché sono piccoli e quindi non
capiscono l'importanza di avere una vita
privata e quindi io arrivo anche a fare
video di questo tipo perché devo
togliermi tutto sto po po di roba una
volta per tutte quindi ragazzi che un
episodio spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto è stato un po strano
perdonatemi però era una di quelle cose
che volevo dire perché
pian piano io farò un set di video dove
rispondo alle domande più frequenti
questa era una di quelle anche le più
scomode e appunto e quindi ragazzi spero
che video vi sia piaciuto il cavalletto
e video è piaciuto lasciato un commento
è un mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook con i risultati scrizione solo
se avessi d'ischia temi ci rivediamo nel
prossimo video beh ragazzi